back in the days of Battlefield Bad
Company a new mode was launched in the
series that gave it a fresh taste both
for vets and casuals of the series that
mode was called rush where you and your
team either destroyed or defended a
series of crates in a fixed location
from your enemies now new on the horizon
is battlefield one which is hoping this
new mode will recapture that excitement
the same way rush did picture if you
will rush and conquest having a baby
that little bastard would be named
operations the setup for this mode may
sound familiar for veterans of the
series a large map consisting of five to
seven battle sections with two or three
captured flags in each the object of
this mode is to capture and hold flags
while the defending team must hold the
line until the ticket count runs out at
any time similar to conquest the
defending team can retake a captured
flag while the game is still fixed in
that battle location if the attacking
team captures all Flags the defenders
will be given a few seconds to either
retake a flag or fall back and put a
better defenses at the next section one
match consists of three rounds
more so in favor to the attacking team
in the last two rounds when the
attacking team is held in a battle
section by the defending team after
round 1 round 2 kicks off with the
summoning of the behemoth for the
attacking team this behemoth as seen in
other modes can either be a battleship
armored train or a Zeppelin each packing
enough firepower to aid the attacking
team to push forward to the defenders
main base at the end of each map
the addition of a behemoth to the
attacking team only is a nice add-on
since through my experience the majority
of the maps favorite bit to the
defenders cup of tea also to add to the
fact is that if the defending team
manages to destroy the behemoth and
round two and hold the enemy either in
the same or new battle section the third
and final round sees the attacking team
getting back a brand new behemoth which
feels a bit unfair given the fact that
most of the rounds I played saw the
first behemoth pushed my team to our
second-to-last base by the end of round
two adding one at the start of round 3
we either find enjoyment by the
community or a mode breaking add-on that
many might want changed right away so
what really makes this better than Rush
well to be honest with you rush was a
great example back when it first
launched on bad company all the way to
where it is today of really tight team
coordinator
tax operations take this a whole nother
step further bigger and wider range of
maps to be used now you don't worry
about planning objectives on crates that
you have to defend or worry about
enemies camping now you can just capture
flags you can stay within their
parameters so you don't to worry about
having to sit around and wait for an
enemy to sneak up behind you you can
kind of planned your attacks to how you
see fit the mode just feels like a
breath of fresh air that many of us who
in plane battlefield for so many years
have really been asking for for quite a
while
in my nine hours of early play no mode
gave me more intense battles than
operations with 64 players running
around in lag free maps like the urban
chaos of arms the deadly Mountain Alps
of Montegrappa
and the blood-stained countryside of San
Quentin's car just to name a few this
mode is set to mix it up in battlefield
multi players world the same as rushed
it back in the start of bad company with
this and so much being thrown into
battlefield one it's shaping up to
possibly be one of the best bow fields
to come out in years what are you
looking forward to doing in operations
do you feel it's fair or unfair for the
attacking team to get a second chance of
controlling a behemoth feel free to
share your thoughts below in the
comments and we will see you guys on the
battlefield
for more on your favorite games keep it
here on GameSpot for more